what's going on my dudes welcome to the
channel I'm Cody Banks and today my news
I'm going to be teaching you how to make
a very simple and efficient crop farm so
let's get started on today's video
to get started on this Farm we're gonna
require the following materials eight
water buckets three stacks of blocks of
your choice two stacks of dirt one stack
of glass of your choice two Hoppers a
handful of redstone one redstone
repeater one button eight dispensers two
chests and then any crop of your choice
you could do seeds for wheat carrots
potatoes or beetroot on the side here
are two water buckets you're gonna need
just two pails of water to make an
infant water pool to lay down some water
to keep your crops hydrated so let's get
started and build this Farm to get
started we're gonna go ahead and build a
double chest right here and behind it
we're gonna go ahead and Crouch and
place our Hopper on the first chest to
verify your Hopper is connected
correctly you will see a tube coming off
of the hopper in whatever Direction the
chest is if your Hopper is placing the
wrong way it will not go into the chest
and your items will not be collected
properly next day we're gonna go eight
blocks backwards from this chest we got
one two three four five six seven eight
just like that then we're gonna put one
block here and one block here we can hop
up on top on top of the chest Crouch
Place piece of glass and let's go seven
back two three four five six seven make
that eight so that way there's two
blocks right here next thing we're gonna
go ahead and grab your block of choice
and beside the hopper one two three four
five six seven eight just like that and
nine
so it should look like this so far
alright so we're ready to put our field
in our first field we're gonna start
back here Place one piece of dirt Place
another piece of dirt and we're gonna go
eight across so we're gonna go all the
way to the glass just to make it easy
and we're gonna go eight back so we got
two three four five six seven and eight
then we're just gonna go ahead and meet
ends and then we'll fill in the center
all right there we have it we have an
eight by eight field our next field we
are gonna do one up here and we're gonna
do an eight by seven so we're gonna go
eight across here just like that then
we're gonna go seven back so we got two
three four five six seven just like that
and then we're gonna meet ends just like
this
and fill it in there we have it so first
field again is an eight by eight second
field is an eight across by seven back
now we're gonna take our block of choice
and we're gonna make a trough for the
water this is basically a little path
here using our blocks so we're gonna
make these paths around the whole farm
that way the water can sit beside the
actual dirt that way it keeps the field
hydrate now this back one here we're
gonna go up like that and then we're
just gonna fill in the back side here
and then we'll start from the front
again make our little water area here
going up like that
and then back here just like that so it
should look like this pretty simple so
far
next thing we're going to go ahead and
make a wall that our water is gonna stay
in because we don't want the water
splashing about so we're gonna just
gonna make that wall kitty corner that
block there that way our Hopper is
protected and the water doesn't get all
over the place then we're going to do
the same thing for this side go ahead
and make a wall that way again the water
stays inside of the trough here it's got
its own little pathway and then put a
block there again all right pretty
simple so far this is the top view just
in case you need help the dirt matches
up with the walls here dirt matches up
with the walls here all right so we're
gonna grab our water buckets we're gonna
make a two by two hole in the ground put
a water bug here water bug here and then
we're gonna go and start so we're gonna
put a water bucket here it's gonna flow
we're gonna put another water bucket
down there it's gonna flow to the end
another water bucket here and another
water bucket right here that way water
is all in these spots make sure there's
water in these spots all right so we're
good to cover this up now so what we're
gonna do is just go ahead and just cover
this up and do a two high wall that way
our crops don't actually fly out of the
farm again do that to this side cover up
the water and then just do a too high
wall and just do that to the other side
as well a too high wall all the way down
the farm here that way the water is
covered up and our crops don't go over
the over the actual wall and then at the
end here add those walls there
[Music]
just like that so that way your whole
Farm is encased next we're gonna go
ahead and grab our dispensers and we're
gonna go one two three four five six
seven eight and then I want you to put
water buckets in every single one of
these dispensers all right once your
water buckets are in the dispensers
we're just gonna go ahead and grab our
block of choice and put it over top of
the dispensers and we're actually gonna
put a block behind the dispensers just
like this and then break that one at the
end
and then we're going to meet these
blocks up here like that and then we're
gonna grab our Redstone out and then
we're gonna make a redstone path with a
button okay go ahead and grab your
Redstone and put it on all these blocks
back here that way you're going to be
able to power up these dispensers and
the water will flow out and auto crop
for you
all the way till the end here now at the
end you want to decide where you want to
place your buttons so I'm going to drop
this block out put a block down here put
a piece of redstone there and then put
the button here now when you click this
button you'll see the Redstone path
travels but it doesn't make it all the
way to the dispenser so we actually have
to place a repeater down now I'm gonna
go two blocks right here so basically
two blocks after the jump and we're
gonna try it we're gonna test it make
sure the water flows all the way
okay all of our buckets are dispensing
so that repeater position is correct
if your buckets aren't dispensing then
you know you'll obviously have to adjust
the repeater accordingly so you either
put it this way or that way
um well you'd put it this way you'd put
it to the left one more but it should
work fine long as you've used the same
blueprint as this one all right now we
can go ahead and just put some glass
walls here just to make it look a little
prettier and our last water bucket is
going to be in this corner right there
now I said you can use two Hoppers it's
totally up to you guys but if you use
two Hoppers you can break that block
there Crouch and place another Hopper
there that way it's connected to this
chest all right so we're going to turn
the farm off
and as you can see the the crops are
going to go back to normal now what
we're gonna do is we are going to
quickly
grab our hoe and we're gonna till the
land and plant some seeds all right dude
so as you can see all the wheat or you
know carrots potatoes beetroot is grown
in and all you're gonna do is go and
click this button and watch the magic
happen as you can see all the crops are
getting harvested automatically and they
are now being placed down into The
Hoppers collected and here we go ready
to check this out we look in this chest
real quick and boom it's all getting
collected up slowly but surely making
its way down into that chest once you
click the button again we can go and
replant the field and then you can do it
all over again once it grows in all
right my dudes if you guys enjoyed this
video don't forget to like comment and
subscribe I really appreciate the sport
and if you guys want me to make another
Farm don't forget to comment down below
what farm you want to see next have
yourself an amazing day my dance peace
out
[Music]
foreign